>> Tucker: EARLIER TODAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP BOWED TO HES
CRITICS AND SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO HALT THE SEPARATION OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AT THE
BORDER.
YOU ASSUMED DEMOCRATS WERE
THRILLED.
THEY GOT WHAT THEY DEMAND AND
OUGHT TO BE CELEBRATING.
THEY ARE NOT SENATOR HARRIS OF
CALIFORNIA TWEETED THIS:
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER DOESN'T FIX
THE CRISIS.
DETAINING CHILDREN WITH THEIR
FAMILIES IN CAMPS IS INHUMANE
AND WON'T MAKE US SAFE.
AND THIS SOUNDED SIMILAR TO HIS
COLLEAGUES:
BY NOW YOU REALIZED LIKE MOST
DEBATES IN WASHINGTON THIS WAS
NEVER ABOUT WHAT THEY CLAIMED IT
WAS ABOUT.
THEY NEVER ARE.
THE LEFT DOESN'T BELIEVE AMERICA
HAS THE RIGHT TO STOP POOR
PEOPLE FROM COMING OVER OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER LEGAL OR NOT.
MOST VOTERS DISAGREE.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE AN
HONEST DEBATE BEFORE THE
MID-TERM ELECTION.
THAT'S THE LAST THING DEMOCRATS
WANT BECAUSE THEY WOULD LOSE THE
DEBATE.
SO THEY ARE WHIPPING THEIR